We compiled a top 10 list of our most anticipated horror films in
2019 here are the frightening films were most excited about in order of theatrical release
2019 is looking pretty scary
Us
in
2017 Jordan Peele redefined the horror thriller with his directorial debut. Get out this year
He goes full-on horror with his follow-up us the opening night film at South by Southwest stars Black Panthers, Winston
Duke and Lupita Nyong'o
Reunited as a married couple with kids who encounter evil
Doppelgangers of themselves the breakout success of get out made Jordan peel one of the hottest new directors to watch the cast
Rounded out by Elisabeth Moss of The Handmaid's Tale and an eerie trailer complete with a throwback remix of loonies
I got five on it has us dying to see it when it opens on March 22nd
Pet Sematary
Mary Lambert's
1989 Pet Sematary made us think twice about burying Fido in the backyard and in April starry eyes directors
Kevin Kolsch and Dennis wide Meyer will try to do the same
The directing duo will close out South by Southwest with the premiere of their take on Stephen King's horror
classic starring Jason Clark and Amy seimetz as the unsuspecting couple who moved to a sleepy town in Maine with their children and
Discover a mysterious burial ground behind their home with John Lithgow on hand. This is one of the more exciting Stephen King movies
We've got coming down the pipeline
The curse of La Llorona
This new horror film centers on the Latin American folk legend
Liya Dona the spirit of a weeping woman whose cries bring misfortune to anyone who hears her sets in 1970s
Los Angeles the film stars Linda Cardellini as a social worker who ignores the warnings of a troubled mother and
discovers she and her family may be the target of
Supernatural evil James Wan the genius behind SAW and the conjuring is in the producers chair
This film should provide a fresh cultural twist on the traditional ghost story when it opens on April 19th
Child's play
Director Lara's club burg updates this 80's horror classic for the 21st century
Complete with a new take on the killer doll Chucky this time around a young mother played by Aubrey Plaza
Gifts her son a high-tech Buddy doll without realizing the toy isn't exactly kid-friendly
Ditching the Voodoo storyline this remake goes full black mirror as buddy rejects his programming and develops a mean streak
Original child's play creator, Don Mancini is apparently not a fan of this new concept
But the franchise has an aged well and an updated reboot with plaza and red-hot star Brian Tyree. Henry could be exactly what it needs
Scary stories to tell in the dark
Executive producer in horror master Guillermo del Toro selected fellow monster lover
Andre over doll as the man to lead an adaptation of this popular children's book series
the film combines multiple stories telling the tale of a group of kids who must unravel the mystery behind a wave of horrific deaths a
Longtime passion project for del Toro even casual fans will agree
He's got a keen eye for terrifying imagery judging from the early glimpses
We've gotten the shape of water director and doll have nailed the look and feel of the books so prepare to relive your childhood trauma
August 9th
Midsummer ari Astor writer director of the insane horror film hereditary is back in the director's chair to terrorize us with a new nightmare
it features Lady Macbeth's Florence Pugh and will Poulter from Bandersnatch as a
Couple who travel to a quaint Swedish village only to be trapped in a bizarre and dangerous competition with a pagan cult
We're giving some serious wicker man vibes from this one and we ain't talking about the Nick Cage not the bees
Mid-summer should be another atmospheric chiller with some good freak out moments see it in theatres August night it chapter 2
The second Stephen King adaptation on our list and EMU sketti returns to direct the sequel of
2017 it's Bill skarsgård is back as penny wise and the adult cast is rounded out by some heavy hitters Jessica Chastain
James McAvoy and Bill Hader who has said scars guards penny wise is even scarier in person
It Chapter two picks up 27 years after the losers club faced off against Pennywise the clown now
They're all grown up and ready to return home for the final showdown
It chapter 2 is arguably the most anticipated horror film of the year and it's in theaters September 6
Dr. Sleep that's right. It's Stephen King yet again, but this time we finally get a sequel to The Shining
Dr. Sleep stars Ewan McGregor as a grown up Danny Torrance who uses the shining to help rescue other children from a cult called the
true not director
Mike Flanagan has made a name for himself on movies like oculus
Ouija origin of evil as well as Netflix's the haunting of Hill House series
Ewan McGregor is joined by Rebecca Ferguson and Jacob Tremblay. Dr. Sleep is in theaters, November 8th
The lighthouse, it's taken a few years, but director Robert Edgar's finally comes through with a follow-up to his critically acclaimed
2016 horror film The Witch
Willem Dafoe and Robert Pattinson lead this
1890s period tale based on seafaring myths about an aging lighthouse keeper named old
shot on 35 millimeter black-and-white film stock and using 1920s and 1940s camera equipment both Dafoe and
Pattinson have described how excruciating and wet
It was during filming which all means that the lighthouse could feel like a throwback to old school horror filmmaking
It's currently set to release sometime in
2019 little monsters
Oscar winner Lupita Nyong'o plays schoolteacher Miss Caroline who takes her class on a field trip to a farm close to a military
experiment while there a zombie outbreak occurs and Miss Caroline must save herself and her
Students earlier reviews out of its Sundance premiere praising young goes commitment to a role that could have felt silly coming from someone else
No release date as of yet, but little monsters looks to make another strong case for yong-go being crowned our next screen clean
What does your most anticipated horror list?
2019 look like let us know in the comments